foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Jade wash all
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
thank you for joining us America we're
going to talk about your life right in
front of you talk about you right in
front of you the phone number is
888-825-5225 you jump in and we'll talk
Michael is going to start this hour he's
in Dallas hey Michael how are you
I'm good Dave how are you guys doing
better than we deserve what's up
um nothing so I'm in an interesting
predicament
um I've incurred about 60k worth of debt
um trying to survive a lawsuit
um I started a company with four
gentlemen down in Austin uh things are
going well this started right at the
beginning of covid and we progressed for
about three years towards the end
there were some let's say Vision
differences
and me and my partner ended up selling
the company to a company out of Houston
and two of the other gentlemen our CTO
and our cro basically stole all of our
intellectual property
and the problem lies I have about a
roughly about a 250 000 stake
um that I'm I'm kind of chasing trying
to figure out what I should do and
whether or not I should I should give up
and call it quits but things have come
basically
sucked me dry and I'm getting kind of
desperate so
yeah I was hoping hoping to get some
guidance
well I don't borrow money and
um I hate your position because this
kind of stuff I'm a redneck it makes me
mad I want to fight to the death
yeah
um yeah and yeah and like you simply
don't have a war chest
yeah and yeah you could go you could go
another sixty thousand dollars in four
years in debt
and still never see any of this
yeah because about the only thing we're
all sure about the court system is that
it sucks
yeah I mean even if you're right it
sucks it takes forever and a lot of
money to prove you're right
and so no one ends up winning as you
figured out but the lawyers
yeah even when you win you lose
and and the other opposing party uh one
of the gentlemen his wife is a lawyer
she's actually a partner at a firm so
they've been very successful at just
burying Us in every which way they can
yeah they're just kicking the cam down
the road dragging it out and making
trying to starve you out
it's not a bad strategy on their part
actually but yeah yeah that's why we
hired him
I mean you said your stake in this is
250 000 Maybe
if that is
so that that's essentially what my my
payout would be but because they have
stolen the intellectual property and
done a split off company uh the company
who bought us pretty much put a pause on
it until you know everything is resolved
because that's that's what they paid for
um
and through just a number of loopholes I
won't bore you with they've basically
been able to pull all of the
I guess most relevant information and
the most uh critical things that we
would need and you know they're they're
really just kind of holding it at this
point just to hurt us or harm us and so
they're not competing with you with the
IP yet
but they've but they've undone your your
sale by holding the out correct yeah
correct yeah they they have they have
the
um in clinic like they're starting a
company that's supposed to do something
similar the company that you sold to do
they have Deep Pockets
they do yes I'd cut a deal with them
go to them let's go to them and let them
fight it and tell them you'll take
you'll deduct the uh the legal fees from
their the stake that they owe you
yeah they owe you 250 if you win right
if you don't win the company that bought
this has got nothing
yeah because they got a competitor in
the marketplace and they don't even have
access to the IP right now you're
telling me
correct yeah so they've got to win or
their sale is bad and what they're doing
is they're saying we're not going to pay
you the 250 until you give us what we
bought which included the IP right
correct yeah
if I'm that company and you came to me
I'll go knock them in the nose because I
got the money
and I did this deal to start with so in
other words they owe you 250 if they
spend 150 on this uh to get it you're
gonna get a hundred
yeah
the the more you don't get otherwise
we we have a number of investors I'm
probably the smallest split about the
total sale of the company was 10 million
dollars yeah well I would go to some of
them then and do the same thing
yeah and just go guys I'm out I can't I
can't do it anymore I I can't I'm not
financing this on a credit card this is
stupid I can't I I'm not I don't have
big enough War chest to stay in the
fight
you know I reached my end so I I'll give
you
if you'll give me credit towards it or
or I'll even discount my share
um and then you you know take my share
of the legal fees out of it and pay me
out if you win good luck I'll be happy
to sign it over to you
on that basis
yeah
yeah well the the issue too is I'm I'm
probably the smallest fish in this
entire equation I'm only 28 most of
these people are 40 just you know longer
careers a little bit more of a war chest
like you said yeah my only concern is
one if that were to be the case I were
to get some sort of payout and then they
end up losing right then you won't get a
payout
yeah yeah they're taking the chance then
not you
that's why you would discount your share
okay so if one of the other investors
said okay we're going to continue the
fight you can't and we'll continue it on
your behalf we're going to take your pro
rata portion of the future legal fees
out of your share and we're also going
to Discount your share since you're not
in the fight anymore
that'd be a deal for you
and it's not a bad deal for them because
you're tapping out either way
because if you tap out and do nothing
and they go win you're gonna get the
full thing so it's a better deal for
them if you offer to let them continue
the fight on your behalf and you give
them credit for that that's a better
deal for them
because there's like 10 or 15 people
playing in this you're saying yeah yeah
this is not a this is a complicated mess
yeah wow
golly some people's children yeah man
yeah that sounds very very very
stressful there's a lot of money at
stake yeah you just can't stay in it
Michael you you've got to find a sugar
daddy to keep you in the deal yeah well
yeah because if he tries to do this
he'll mess around and spend all his
steak on lawyers fees and he won't even
even then he got at least he wins but he
gets nothing that's what I'm saying if
he goes 250 000 in debt and then loses
oh then he's yeah double completely
screwed yeah you know so you just gotta
stop Michael you got to stop but I would
sell out my part to somebody the buyer
or the other investors or somebody at a
discount yeah
um in today or if they want to give you
cash that'd be awesome or if uh or
better yet I would discount it and offer
to have them reduce the amount by the my
share of the attorney's fees going
forward my 115th or whatever that ends
up being like you said you're in a
untenable situation this is why we don't
believe in Partnerships around here boys
and girls the only ship that Won't Sail
is a partnership this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys Jade Washington Ramsey
personality is my co-host we're heading
to Chicagoland in the morning we'll be
doing a smart conference there Friday
night and uh all day Saturday all the
Ramsey personalities speaking on career
on life and money and uh of course on uh
anxiety and all the other things that Dr
John deloney talks about so we're going
to be talking about every area of your
life in one way or another it's a
day-long our day and a half long
adventure it is a blast it's a lot of
fun if you're in the Chicagoland area
we'll be on the Willow Creek Campus
utilizing their Sanctuary to do the
event and we'd love to have you we've
got some tickets left check it out at
ramseysolutions.com events also uh you
should know that the first two hours on
Saturday morning we have decided we're
going to live stream that free and
that'll be uh a little bit from me but
mostly Jade and George's talk uh Georgia
Campbell's talk and Jade's talk about
how you can break free from money stress
and create the debt free future you
deserve so if you want to hear a free
money talk from Jade and George just
Tune In by free live stream go to
ramseysolutions.com live drop in your
email we'll send you the link on
Saturday morning you can watch that live
and be about an hour a little more than
an hour's worth of content total there
for that whole thing so we'd love to
have you guys and come in and join us if
you're not able to be in the Chicago
area if you're in the Chicago area you
don't want to miss this these smart
conferences you know when you leave a
smart conference um you're smart there
you go that's good our question of the
day comes from neighborly your hub for
Home Services they are your one place to
find Reliable HVAC plumbing and
electrical providers near you Brands
like air serve Mr Rooter and Mr Electric
have professionals ready to help stop
wasting time scrolling through pages of
results just go to neighborly.com
they'll help you they're good people
they are and today's question comes from
David in Oklahoma he says my wife and I
have started Financial Peace University
way to go we're on baby step two and we
have some questions currently we have
four vehicle payments and I recently
lost my job we're living off my wife's
salary and unemployment payments we keep
hearing about people selling their
vehicles and buying cheap cars how is
this done when you're upside down
very good uh we are upside down on all
four vehicles and we want to know how to
downsize we are thinking about
surrendering the motorcycles but that
will end up costing us around 16k after
we sell them any help would be great as
we are determined to get debt free okay
so I actually have a list that they've
given me here so they've got her truck
which is 852 dollars good God a month by
the way they've got her oh no I'm sorry
that was his truck they've got her SUV
for 677 dollars a month and then they've
got two motorcycles once 555 the other
one's 408. now he doesn't tell me how
far upside down they are I'm gonna
assume I think she's 16 on the
motorcycles yeah wrong
well why do you think he's wrong well
because he thinks that that if he said
if that they're going to give him full
price in a repo if you do a voluntary
repo and you take people the keys they
sell your crap on a repo lot
oh he had you're right he said
surrendering don't do that don't do that
if they sell it on a repo lot they sell
it for below wholesale at a repo price
and they sue you for the difference and
it ain't gonna be 16 dude it's gonna be
25 if you do that so you don't you don't
surrender you don't do a voluntary
repossession they may take them at some
point if you can't get up right up on
the payments but but don't ever
voluntarily because you lose control of
the sale price and then you've got to
work out a settlement for the difference
the deficit balance so no no on the
surrender oh yeah definitely try to sell
them now these cars uh yeah 852 677
dollars that's incredibly too high for
car payments I don't know how far upside
down they are again but the idea here is
how quickly can you get some cash
stacked up all right so what I'm doing
is if I'm you as I know you're on baby
step two but I would pause baby step two
for a second so I could stack up all the
money you need to get out of this deal
because essentially this is part of baby
step too so if you've got a lot of your
margin going out to extra payments stop
doing that and start stacking up as much
cash as you can and since you're in baby
step two hopefully that means that
you're working overtime I know you lost
your job but right now
now is not the time to wait for your
dream job to come along right now get
any jobs you can right yeah
right and take all that money you can
drive because you've got a lot of things
to drive that's true look delivery
service is out the Wazoo yeah now put
the kids on the motorcycle to deliver
pizzas so you got three things you can
do when you're upside down one-ish stack
cash and cover the difference so you got
a a truck that's you know let's just I
can't even get past it I know 852. puke
but the um the her SUV okay 677 so she
owes 60 000 bucks on the SUV and when
they look it up it's worth 50. I may get
those numbers up so let's say that means
your ten thousand dollars upside down
how do you cover that well one you stack
ten thousand dollars and then you put
that with the money with the buyer that
the buyer has at 50 and you've got 60.
now you pay off the SUV and they send
you the title and you give it to the
buyer that's one way second way is
borrow the difference from your local
Credit Union or for God's sakes
600 852 dollars if you borrow the
difference on a credit card you're still
come out yeah okay you're already eight
bazillion dollars in debt now your
credit is not just one bazillion dollars
in debt and now it's just not now you're
truckless oh well yeah it's kind of goes
along being clueless so um yeah even if
your credit is shot and you can't get a
good rate from a credit union
it's still debt you're just moving the
debt around all right and then the third
thing is a modification of that if your
truck loan or motorcycle loans are with
your local lender your local credit
union your local bank
go sit down with them in person
and say
hi I'm unemployed
you're getting ready to get a truck back
you'll want it I don't think you do
turns out this SUV we owe 60 000 on it
with you guys it's worth 50.
you need to help us get out of this so
you don't get stung
this is you talking to your credit union
or bank manager in person not on the
phone and for God's sakes not by email
yeah go sit down and look them in the
eye
in person
and what we want you to do Mr bank
manager is allow us to sign the note for
the difference when it sells so we're
going to put the SUV up for sale for
fifty two thousand it's going to sell
for 50 and we're going to come in here
and we're going to sign an unsecured
note for ten thousand dollars because
you already have an unsecured note for
ten thousand dollars because you have a
sixty thousand dollar loan on a fifty
thousand dollar asset
so you are already ten thousand dollars
unsecured all we're doing with this
transaction is admitting it and lowering
our debt by five sixths therefore we
have a higher probability of actually
paying you because we can survive and so
you talk them into converting the upside
down portion into an unsecured note
which by the way it's already where they
are they're already unsecured for that
amount yeah and you can do that if you
go in person and present this logic to
them plus you're you know you're a
bankruptcy looking for a place to happen
right now and in which case they get a
whole bunch of new trucks sitting in
their driveway at the bank and uh
they're going to get nothing yeah
because they sue you for the deficit you
get nothing in bankruptcy on the deficit
zero they do and something tells me I
don't know I could be wrong uh David in
Oklahoma but something tells me with
these trucks and vehicles you got more
stuff laying around to get rid of you've
got riding lawyers collects toys he's
got riding mowers he's got a Peloton
he's got he there's some stuff that can
be sold and liquidated a bunch of stuff
a bunch of look at everything don't tell
me you have a tractor I'll kill you
don't kill me just don't tell me right
now sell Dave choosing violence just
sell the tractor no I mean I know this
guy because I was this guy yeah and I'm
just a boy that collects toys yeah and
the problem with the boy that collects
toys is we collect payments with them if
we're broke people do they have a golf
cart too uh uh they might have a golf
cart so man yeah that and yeah there's
they for sure have a zero turn that's
six thousand bucks
for sure I was
I didn't know that a lawnmower costs
that much I didn't know Dave until I saw
him sitting out there and I was like
wait a second you've got to be careful
there's a lot of lawn mowers that are
nicer and more expensive than my first
three cars
they have because my none of my first
three cars had Bluetooth I'm just saying
so the tractor has Bluetooth the zero
turn has Bluetooth definitely what what
yeah cause you have to listen to your
tunes while you take 10 minutes to mow
your yard she thinks my tractor sex
that's what y'all are listening to there
you go that's it no she don't she thinks
you're broke cause you are sorry Jason
Aldean yeah there we go this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
are one
guarantee and
at blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
visit blinds.com to get up to 45 percent
off that's
blinds.com rules and restrictions May
apply
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Derek is in San Diego hi
Derek how are you
Mr Ramsey how about yourself sir better
than I deserve what's up
glad to hear glad to hear
um basically I wanted to discuss my
current situation with saving money I'm
28 years old I make about 105 at my
current role and another 25
000 uh in side work through flipping
items
and I am saving about three to four
thousand dollars every month after all
my expenses I don't have like a car loan
or anything of that nature and
um sometimes I worry that you know maybe
I'm not enjoying life as much as I would
like because I'm just so focused on
saving money and budgeting and
calculating my net worth every two weeks
um
so I just want to get your guidance on
when you really decide and how you can
tell
you know that you need to start enjoying
life more with the money that you've
seen one more time you got 25 coming in
on a side hustle and what's the other
what's your core of income
uh my W-2 every year is 105 000. okay so
you're making like 130k with your side
Hustle
correct and you're saving like four a
month okay cool yes yes I think that's
great you know one of the reasons that
we walk through the baby steps is it
kind of gives you
um guidance for each area of your life
and then it also not only the guidance
but it gives you the permissions to do
what you want to do with your money so
in your case if you have no debt right
you have no debt at all of any kind I
don't have
I have a car that's you know 18 years
old do you have any debt of any kind
not at all no student alone
uh my father is taking care of that
that's an agreement we had
how much is a student loan
it's uh 16 000. whose name is it in
in my father's and mine if it
if it's in your father's and your first
thing it's either a Parent PLUS Loan in
his name or it's in your name
I believe then it technically isn't my
name yeah I think technically it is if
it's in your name you gotta pay that
kind of like you're in debt yeah yeah I
paid off like technically okay so how
much money do you have saved like how
much money did you ever put inside
uh we'll save right now I have about 130
000. how much is the student loan
16 about 16 000. good pay it off today
pay it off today now your savings is it
what where is it is it just sitting in a
high yield savings account
I have some in some Vanguard accounts
and then also 401k and about 60 000 in
uh two bank accounts okay so the sixty
thousand that's in the two bank accounts
pull pull some of the 16 000 to pay off
the loan how much credit card debt do
you have
uh none I just use debit I've been
following you for a long time okay well
shorter yeah so then you unders okay
then you understand the baby steps so
your art are you already investing 15 or
more uh yes more than that okay where do
you live are you renting are you owning
uh I currently rent okay so now we are
now that's what I was saying before
we're using the baby steps to figure out
what we should be doing how we should be
spending so at this point if I'm you
instead of over funding the 15 I'd
probably start focusing on a down
payment because at some point you're
going to want to stop renting you're
going to want to have control over that
biggest line item on your budget right
you don't want to rent forever rent is
going up it's always fluctuating right
so if I were you instead of doing over
15 I would stop that cut it at 15 and
then I would take your extra margin put
some of it to a down payment right
that's baby step 3B and then you get to
decide how intense you want to be about
this right you can decide if you're
going to just go hard in the paint or if
you want to pull back it's like you know
what I'm young I got you know it doesn't
have to be that intense at this point
does that make sense yeah you're running
on gazelle intensity and now that your
student loan is paid off you don't have
to do that so here's what I would do I
pay your student loan off your dad has
promised to pay it I heard you loud and
clear he can pay you back
if he wants to pay anything but I don't
want this in your name anymore I want it
gone so you pay it off today so your 105
000 in savings has been reduced by 16
000. we'll take a portion of that and
allocate it to your emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses the rest
of that you can allocate is a down
payment now back to your question when
do you enjoy life uh now now you need to
budget some fun in your budget all you
do safe
and you need to have some fun on your
budget and you need to have some
generosity in your budget that you don't
have too and you'd be helping some other
people
right you make 130 000 a year you're 20
something years old you don't have any
debt yeah you ought to have you ought to
have some fun and you ought to save some
and invest some and you ought to have
some generosity you gotta always have
all three things in your budget
once you're at your stage
okay so for the rest of your life like
Derek when Sharon and I get a check in
from a publisher or something these days
it's extra money we have a formula we
apply to it okay we take out you know 40
for taxes 10 for tithe at least 50
percent now then
um
after that uh uh because rich people pay
all the taxes man when you said 40 just
let me help you with that okay but
anyway but aside from that the um so
then we apply the uh put the other 50
goes to three things and we have a set
percentage for more fun more generosity
and more investing
out of that other 50. okay like one of
my friends does that he puts 30 in
investing increases his lifestyle by
five and puts 15 into extra generosity
and that gets you to your 50. okay so
the you know you work it out but be my
point is not necessarily the percentages
or even that you have to have a formula
for it but you ought to always have all
three in there absolutely and if you
have all three in there then you've got
a pretty good balanced life because once
you're out of debt other than the house
which you are today because you just
paid off your student loan if you really
follow us now and then you put have your
emergency fund set aside once your bass
baby step three yeah you go from intense
which is what you've been living to
intentional intentional means we're
investing some additional generosity and
additional fun yeah that's good yeah and
you can so if you've been wanting to
upgrade the dot dot dot the car that's
the fun because his car is old yeah okay
you got it you're driving a beater then
yeah let's let's upgrade the car and you
probably have the money to do that of
your emergency fund even after you pay
off the student loan today yeah he will
because he had at least 60 000 sitting
at 104. oh that's right but some of it I
think was invested oh well but it wasn't
invested in IRAs he said 401K okay we
don't touch that yeah don't touch the
401K okay okay that's good yeah but
either way either way still still going
to end up being the same thing so good
question sir good question thank you for
joining us so guys um
foreign
the things that we teach they're they're
everywhere I mean you go through
Financial Peace University you get a
detailed line-by-line thing of okay make
sure what you guys talked about on the
uh uh live stream the other night you
and Rachel make sure you don't have a
three thousand dollar tax refund right
okay adjust that that's one of the
things we teach make sure you're not
sitting on whole life life insurance
make sure you're not sitting on
investments that are non-retirement
while you're sitting on debt on the
other side that's right cash that down
to a thousand bucks and get it all clean
you know start throwing it at your debt
make sure you're working your debt
snowball smallest to largest balance
that's right your interest rate make
sure you're on a written budget in an
agreement with your spouse you know
there's about eight or ten things like
that yeah that you do that you go
through if you say you're following us
then you're really doing it that's right
you're doing the baby steps the baby
steps say when you're in one through
three temporarily stop all investing
while you're in baby step two getting
out of debt and while you're getting
your emergency fund built but here's the
thing all investing not just down I sort
of did I started follow you you can't
you're either doing your thing or you're
doing on our thing okay so this stuff
works but to the but every time you dial
back one of these eight or ten things
and don't do that you slow your butt
down well and you mess yourself it just
slows you down it's a prescription when
you go to the doctor and they say you're
sick here's what you need and they write
it out for you and you take it and cash
it in you don't go and choose I'm I'm
gonna take that one I'm not gonna take
that one you know what don't give me
that medicine give me this one if you do
that you'll get sick and you can die you
know the number I read this the other
day what book was I reading
I guess it was Jordan Peterson's book uh
I was asking deloney about this I
couldn't believe it the number of people
that go to the doctor and the doctor
gives them a prescription that never
fill it yeah I know and then the number
of people that fill the prescription and
don't take a stinking man you're messing
with your health I mean so what was the
point well I went to the Healer to do
nothing that he said that's dumber than
crap I do not understand
I don't I mean I like doctors but I
don't want to go see one okay people die
over there I don't want to go see them
but I I mean I want to I I I but if I'm
gonna go I'm gonna do it then I said
take the medicine I mean I do not
understand yeah okay so yeah do this
stuff exactly not because it doesn't
affect me we don't make more money if
you do just it's good for you
foreign
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow is
Catholic you can tailor the content
towards your faith tradition if you
don't have a faith tradition this great
place to learn more about it from
scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Halo is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hollow.com Ramsay today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
good
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for being with
us Melissa is in Mobile Alabama I'm
Melissa how are you
I'm better than I deserve Mr Ambien I
bet you're just the same just the same
yeah how are things in L.A
oh Al yes lower Alabama come on
so um I've actually just have two quick
questions one I'm curious what the what
a good ratio is between home value and
net worth and then secondly I kind of
become the uh
person in my family that people go to
for advice so to help myself be a little
bit more efficient try to start
purchasing Ramsey Plus for all of them
well that would break our heart
we would hate it that's funny call up we
might get you a bulk deal
um
um the ratio will change as your net
worth goes up that's not a set ratio
here's here's my point
um what we found among millionaires the
typical millionaire when we studied the
10 000 of them for the baby steps
millionaires book
um was that the typical person from one
to five million dollar net worth
they oftentimes sounded like we got a
million and a half dollar net worth and
we have a 500 000 paid for house and
about a million dollars in our 401ks and
Roth IRAs so about a third
of their net worth was in their home
when they reached that level
as you increase your net worth your home
should be a smaller percentage
so if you have a hundred million dollar
net worth you wouldn't necessarily want
to you would you would not want a 33
million dollar house
if you had 100 million dollar net worth
that would be inappropriate see so
one-third doesn't apply then right and
if you go down and you say okay I got a
500 000 net worth well a lot of times
there you're going to find the house to
be about half of it
I paid for it I paid for a house okay so
if 250 000 house 250 000 in mutual funds
in their 401ks at 500 000 would be
fairly normal but that's the point is
there's not an exact but it does it does
shift the further up the net worth goes
my home is a very small percentage of my
net worth these days but I'm really
blessed I mean the buildings we're
sitting in are worth 600 million so
um you know that's certainly my home is
a small or much small percentage of that
so that it would be absurd for sharing
how to do that so uh uh so if you were
at the point of uh and I'm asking this
question because Melissa I don't know
where you're going with this but if
you're at the point where like maybe
maybe I'm looking to retire but your
home is the greater portion of your net
worth and you know your your assets your
Investments are not then maybe you think
about downsizing your home so you can
liquidate some of that money yeah you
might because the home is you know if
you're sitting there with a five million
dollar net worth and a four million
dollar house a lot of your net worth is
not earning an income then right
our net worth I have a 500 000 paid for
house today and I just kind of feel like
if I want that's perfect yeah upgrade
one day I just don't know what you can
upgrade you can upgrade you can you know
but I but I would upgrade it at a 2.2 to
a half no I wouldn't I wouldn't go that
far
okay you can but I mean every dot you
know the high because that is a uh at
this point your home is yes it's an
asset but it is a consumption because
it's not producing income
so out of the 2.2 every dollar that's in
the house is not income producing so the
fewer dollars in the house and right now
you've got about one or you got about
what 1.7 that is producing income
right
and and your 500 isn't but if you went
up you know to seven eight hundred
thousand that wouldn't be out of line at
all and also your net worth is going to
be increasing while this happens wait oh
you killed it at 34 years old I know
you're a stud at girl what you're
amazing how'd you do that
uh
just I don't like I don't know just the
same thing
the same thing I'm pretty boring I'm
pretty boring there you go well I mean
you don't you have a life I mean did you
just invested and stayed out of debt
tell me what you did I don't put words
in your mouth but yeah yes sir I mean to
be fair I was never in baby step two so
I'm kind of a fraud but no no you're not
you're just smart no that means you have
parents
you can go you can go kiss your mama she
helped you I mean your family had common
sense I kept you out of debt
yes sir
instead of telling you to buy purses
people can't pronounce okay and it just
goes to show what a difference it makes
when you avoid debt your entire life as
opposed to what I did and what so many
people did which they got into debt and
then had to dig themselves out then they
had to start what's your income
[Music]
it's about three hundred thousand what
do you do
yeah I'm an engineer number one number
one uh career field in the millionaire
study Bert the one that occurred the
most often second was accounting third
was teacher
so yeah yeah so you you fit all the mat
you fit all the math except you're a
little bit ahead like way ahead you're
amazing well done it's really good very
cool talking to you yeah you're gonna do
fine you're not gonna make a dumb
decision here but um it's a good
discussion because net worth is
there's a number
that you can look at to tell if you're
winning with money the FICO score is not
a number that you can tell you're
winning with money because you could you
can get you can your boss can walk in
today and give you a raise of a million
dollars a year and your FICO score
doesn't change a dime yeah
yeah that's true it's like uh the FICO
score is have you ever gone Dave to a
restaurant and the food looks really
good like it looks good on the outside
and then you eat it and it doesn't taste
anything like what you were hoping it
would taste like kind of like those like
those hotels in the Bahamas of the
website doesn't look anything like it
yes yes it's a catfish and that's where
the credit score is you you I've got a
credit score is the financial catfish I
never that's it you're hurting you're
trying to figure this out for 30 years
you got it you heard it here first
America that's it the FICO score is the
financial catfish the credit card is the
financial cigarette that's right it's
going to end up being the worst thing
that you ever did but back when you were
young all the cool kids did
right oh my gosh that's exactly what it
is it's a complete lie it's been
photoshopped
to look like you better than you is
that's right because you don't look
nothing like that oh I'm just saying
yeah so the credit score is 100 derived
from your interaction with debt the
algorithm that fair Isaac developed
which is the organization that creates
the FICO score uh says that every
element of the the creation the
mathematical creation of your has
something to do with debt yeah you know
how much debt are you late on your debt
did you pay off your debt early all
these elements run run into your credit
score the if you had a 25 million dollar
net worth and zero debt for six months
your credit score would be zero that's a
trip
so your net worth what Melissa's doing
is the way to measure it the real way
what's the opposite of a catfish the ooh
a bass a real fish a real fish not a
fake fish a beauty queen that's right
that's right your net worth is your
beauty queen and your FICO score is a
catfish
it's fake winning it's fake Beauty it
isn't really there yeah it's an avatar
yeah so good we can really do stuff with
it we can this is right here yeah the
internet the internet's good for
something after all there you go great
analogy yeah so
yeah so Melissa at 34 years old 2.2
million dollar net worth inherited
nothing is giving away Ramsay plus which
is Financial Peace University and every
dollar together that's what that is
she's giving that away in bulk to her
family when they ask her financial
advice because they very wisely come to
her at 34 years old with a 300 000
income and a 2.2 million dollar net
worth 100 debt free 500 000 of it in her
house they very wisely ask her advice we
always tell you donut if your broke
friends are making fun of your financial
plan you're right on track yeah that's
true but if you're rich Melissa is
telling you you're doing good now
Melissa tells you you did good let me
just tell you she knows what good looks
like well she doesn't have to give
advice she just lives advice and they
see it when then they just saddle up
they are can we buy you a cup of coffee
and tell us how you did that that's the
fruit the fruit doesn't lie that's it
yeah it's very attractive yes to win it
is as opposed to fake win that's right
catfishing catfish Mission the real the
real deal noodling oh my gosh
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
all right
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America Jay barshall Ramsay personality
is my co-host today Phil and Green Bay
Wisconsin starts this hour hi Phil how
are you
better than I should be Dave how are you
it's the same sir how can I help
well Dave
um my question is my wife and I are
looking at early retirement and we've
taken time over the last 30 plus years
of being together
cutting Corners saving as we can and
really want to take time to uh if we can
give back more we do a bit of
volunteering locally as well as
nationally and uh with our kids grown
and gone want to find out if you think
we're in a position where we can not
really join the Fire crowd but step into
retirement Okay cool so your house is
paid for
our house is paid for good for you
what's it worth
uh four and a quarter good for you cool
what's the rest of your nest egg look
like
uh currently we've got about 2.2 in IRA
and 401ks combined we currently have an
additional uh 300K that we've invested
in bonds government bonds currently that
invest in October separately
um we obviously aren't at the age I'm
currently going to be retiring if we do
at 60 my wife will be 57. I'm looking at
Social Security deferring out at 62
would be like 23 for me and it's 67
33.50 approximately on the current
schedules for me my wife at uh 67 would
be at 1900.
and we currently have a pension that uh
if I took it early which I'm looking at
not doing but it'd be about 1200 a month
if I took it at 62 it would push out to
uh about 16 and that at 65 would be
2200. and what do you guys need what do
you guys need a month to live well
our current budget as we as we do it
we're sitting at around 45 000 on a
monthly to run our two properties and uh
we live comfortably Dave we've um you
know always made concessions and saved
when we could but um
yeah we're thinking that's probably
going to be what we're going to need to
to you know that doesn't include travel
you need double you need to double that
yeah you know you're thinking that is
the case right yeah yeah I mean you can
survive on 45 but I want you to thrive
okay no totally that's why I've done
what we've done yeah so 2.2 were that
invested in good mutual funds and were
you accessing it
um if it made uh 11. 11.6 which is what
the stock market has averaged since it
began
um you know that'd be 250 000 a year
yeah where we're at right now that's
kind of yeah so the other thing I forgot
to mention is that we do currently have
an emergency fund of 50k in savings
um it's in a high yield um but again
what we're kind of thinking is
um probably with the four percent rule
thinking that through there's probably
gonna be a little low so wanted to get
your direction on you know if you think
it's viable that we could pull the
trigger and if so I think the 40 rules
absolute bull crap it has nothing to do
with anything that's crap that people
drew up on the Internet so let's talk
about the reality okay the reality is
for the last 72 years the Consumer Price
Index has averaged 4.2 percent that is
the measure of inflation under Biden we
had one year of 9.6 percent but the
average inflation rate for the last 10
years is 2.3 percent
okay so inflation if you average
inflation at four that's fine okay that
that's a four percent rule you could
count on so in other words your cost of
living your cost of buying a loaf of
bread buying uh electricity gasoline for
your car for the next 40 years from 60
to 100 is going to go up at about four
percent a year in the last 10 years it
would have gone up 2.3 percent a year
average okay
now if you do that and you've got it
invested in
just an S P 500 which means you're just
performing at the market level of 11
11 minus four is seven
so mathematically if you pull seven out
of your account which you don't need to
do you don't need the money okay right
but if you if you pulled seven out of
your account and left four in there your
account is going to grow by four percent
a year so it will grow by enough to
where the next year the seven percent
will cover the increased cost of goods
you build inflation into the system and
that system right there would run
mathematically in perpetuation you would
never lose
so this idea that you can only pull off
four percent is absolute hogwash okay
and so you know now do you need to pull
off more than four percent no but that's
not a rule that's a rule some Financial
nerd came up with that is doubling down
on hyper conservative and they're not
using good sets of assumptions so I just
call BS on that anyway not fussing at
you but I get this crap from these
people all the time and occasionally I
need to hit back so I just did okay now
the uh so what would I do I would set up
your accounts to draw 90 000 a year
minus your pension minus your Social
Security
which probably is going to be you're
gonna pull off sixty thousand so you're
doubling your you're doubling your and
so if you're pulling 60 Grand off of 2
million you're pulling off three percent
you follow me yeah oh no I do yep and
then I got two million still gonna keep
growing
right on no I follow you and I think we
aren't planning to tap into that because
again we've got 300K that we you know
rolled in that'll vest and mature in
October and um that's kind of something
we can fall back on we're thinking that
we'll probably roll that back for
another you know if it maintains at five
or above
um just to have access to that when you
say fall back on what do you mean by
that why would it be a five or above
what are you talking about the stock
market
um well no I'm thinking that we
that we would have some
have grown and gone and professional
lives but if we wanted to for example uh
vacation for a winner in Florida or
whatever additional funds that we'd have
beyond our original
um you know 60 70 000 that you're
talking about after pension and social
security if you follow me it was just
additional cash and we're thinking
rather than 300K though could be sitting
in an investment it doesn't have to be a
five percent yeah he could put it no I
follow you that's why I said I don't
want I don't want to deal with five
percent numbers five percent numbers are
for short-term money
you make five percent on a high yield
savings account right now and that's
stuff you need to access the next six
months not the next 16 years
so you got you got enough money you're
not going to be fooling with your money
dude you need to keep it all fully
invested and just pull what you need to
pull off the income out there and you
can use whichever Source you want to use
I don't care but I would be in good
growth stock mutual funds that's what I
am I'm 63. that's where my stuff is I'm
gonna pull the dime out it's all sitting
in good growth stock mutual funds I'm
not even pulling an income off of it
because I'm still working yeah and so
um you know the the uh but
the point being that that
um you know you can count on like this
year I mean I don't even look at the s p
this week but it was like 17 the last 12
months you would have made if you were
in the standard and poor which is the
stock market if you're invested in good
mutual funds while everybody's sitting
around whining about the Biden economy
and how horrible everything is and the
interest rates are ridiculous and the
housing markets have gone to crap and
everybody's talking about all this stuff
Meanwhile your freaking 401K went up 17
nobody ever talks about that yeah well
it's not good it's good news good news
isn't broadcast and by the way if I were
him I would wait till he's 65 on that
pension he doesn't need the money so he
may as well wait so he can get more of
it as long as everybody's healthy I
would push off return I'd push off the
pension and the social as long as
everybody's healthy this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
to wrong Is With Us in West Palm Beach
Florida hey Tyrone what's up
hey Mr Ramsey how are you doing today
how can we help
so basically uh I'm 30 I just turned 32
years old I'm got married last year uh
with my beautiful wife she's amazing uh
we well this past this April uh we
decided to get him our own house uh
currently be living in it we have a very
traditional value where we live with of
our parents but well and at the time
that we couldn't find a house she moved
down here uh after we got married
um we decided to buy a house the house
won't be uh built until next year so we
uh we talked we spoke with the Builder
and the community
um that the new community complex is
building that we purchase a house the
house with the closing and everything is
going to be about 731
000 and we me and my wife have uh I I in
my opinion I would say if you have a
pretty good Financial standpoint but
with this a lot of this interest rates
and a lot of things like keep going up
it kind of thy doubts me so what we
decided on agreed upon was we're going
to be putting about 275 uh down payment
on the house so she has a very good job
she's a nurse manager uh she brings uh
six figures in and I'm up uh I'm a
basically a financial advisor uh I bring
somewhere around six figure as well okay
so you have a 200 250 000 income or a
400 000 income what kind of six figure
are you talking about
still she's in there the nurse and I
just she bring she brings about a
hundred and fifteen thousand what do you
mean and I I make about 100 and I'm on
right now I looked it up I'm on track to
hit about 113
000. okay so 230. all right and uh you
have 200 000 saved or more how much do
you have saved
uh so current uh well we don't have 100
we don't We're not gonna put
275 until sometimes the next year
probably June or July of next year right
now I have uh in my investment account
about 122
000 and obviously we're gonna have a
track uh we have a plan in place where
from now uh the time that we booked on
April until next year we're gonna be
taking 90 of the income putting it to
the side for the house and you have no
doubt
I I have I don't have that uh I've never
been to the college or anything I pretty
much work my whole life out and
everything so uh this was like for me I
I've been uh watching your show and
being like listening to how you give
advice I've been following that okay so
basically everything you can scrape
together before the closing is a couple
hundred grand you're gonna put that as
your down payment
absolutely so you have a 500 000
mortgage with a two hundred and thirty
thousand dollar income sounds good how
can we help yep so basically like what
scares me here is like where now my me
and my wife like talk about it like you
know what because I keep track of all
this interest rate what we're at are we
doing well in our planning and
everything
where she and I are in like we're in the
age of early 30s we're like she wants to
have like Family Planning set aside
something for kids like college gaming
I'm not sure if we could like get all
this covered within the boundary are you
worried that you won't have it like once
you get into this house payment you
won't have enough margin to do the
things that you want to do like have a
family and you know just live life
that's what you're saying yeah yeah so
she's all about traveling I'm not fully
all like all traveling and everything no
you're a child yeah look with what you
just laid out for us you're well within
the bounds we always say for the payment
not to be more than 25 of your take-home
pay you're do are you doing this on a
15-year fixed that's the only other part
of this discussion uh no it's gonna be
30 years no it's gonna be 15. that's
that's where you need to that's yeah you
need to be on 15 year the lower interest
rate to start with and also you need to
get a game plan where you have a house
that's going to be paid off someday and
then yeah if you'll live on a written
detailed budget that the two of you
agree to you can close on this house and
you should have plenty of margin to have
a decent life and continue and just
continue to invest on a 15-year fixed
rate and your income is going to
continue to go up exactly and if the
interest rates drop in the future
refinance and get rid of a higher rate
because you could still be in a higher
interest rate environment by next April
that's possible I'm hoping they'll come
down by then we will be in a
presidential election year and they have
a tendency to go down in those years so
but um no guarantee of that but uh yeah
so if you end up closing in the seven
eight percent world and then they drop
drop to six we'll refinance it later but
in the meantime dude take out a 15 you
can do this you've got margin let me
tell you what I hear okay I hear a
financial guy who's really good with
math and you've converted that to
worrying hmm
don't ring your hands
plan enjoy the ride
plan
enjoy the ride
but no plans ever come out exactly like
you've got them projected 18 years into
the future with your spreadsheet 2 A.M
you can't you can go to sleep plan enjoy
have peace it's gonna be okay you're
gonna be fine Eric is with us in
Richmond Virginia hi Eric welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave and Jade how are you all doing
today better than we deserve how can we
help
good I am fired up I just got married in
May my wife and I and um we just started
Financial Peace University a couple
weeks ago cool um and so we started and
we did step one we're done with that
good but in step two we're a little
scared
um good just having a thousand dollar
emergency fund there it's not enough
it's scary it's supposed to be scary
yeah
here here what do we we do if we have
like a five thousand dollar you know pet
bill or transmission Bill what's gonna
happen let me let me break this I just
talked about this last night when you
get to this stage that you're at when
you have a thousand dollars and this is
for everybody listening not just uh Eric
it changes the way you think okay when
you before you had the thousand dollars
right and you had a credit card or you
had this fake emergency uh this fake
safety net there right if something
happens the dog gets sick right and the
vet says it'll be five thousand dollars
you just Fork over the five thousand
because you're not thinking straight
you're thinking oh I put on my credit
card or I'll do this but when you have a
thousand dollars and things like that
come up your brain starts working a lot
more efficiently you start becoming a
lot more creative and you start
realizing what's in need what's a want
can I be resourceful is there another
way to go about this and that's the
beauty of a thousand dollars like when
the dryer goes out before when you had
credit cards it's like well I'll just go
down to Lowe's and get me a new dryer
and let me get the newest nicest model
right but when when you have a thousand
you go oh my gosh my mother-in-law lives
up the street I'm gonna go over there
and dry the clothes for a little while
until I can save up a couple thousand
dollars and then I'm gonna go over here
and I'm gonna buy this one on Craigslist
or I'm gonna buy this one that's on sale
at Home Depot right your brain starts
working better and you start getting
creative and that's how this works
now how much debt do you guys have
uh between student loans and credit
cards
um we're at about 88 000 and what's your
household income
uh after taxes were a little over 100
like 102. okay all right and um how much
do you owe in your car
[Music]
this is at 14. okay and that's included
in the 88.
it is yeah all right and so you're
debt-free in two years
you know here's what's the number of
emergencies that happen over one
thousand dollars in a two-year period of
time is very very small
if it comes up deal with it then but
it's not going to come up okay and
um uh and you'll be shocked and amazed
my husband and I had a thousand dollars
did you ever have a thing when you were
you were seven years that's what I'm
saying did you go seven years with a
thousand dollars well yeah I mean we'd
use it if there's an emergency
no would you I mean how'd you if you had
a 2000 what did you do you just have to
make it you have to figure out a way to
make it work and then stack up cash you
talk to the vet and go Fluffy's you know
we're gonna do something else with
fluffy oh please yeah by the way set a
limit ahead of time with the pets okay
and then there's it decides for you yeah
I'm you know they're they're I I love my
dog almost as much as I love my kids but
they're a dog they're not a kid so we
kind of have to keep this somewhat in
perspective so yeah I'm not trying to
get all you I know all you Fur People on
my in my you do have to set limits too
but oh well and you have to decide can
you afford a pet you might not be able
to afford a pet this is the Ramsey Show
oh
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage trampus and Jill are with us
hi guys how are you hey how are you
welcome welcome where do y'all live
Knoxville Knoxville Tennessee and how
much debt have you paid off just a
little over 126 000. okay very good how
long did this take 22 months good for
you and your range of income during that
time we went from 110 to a little over
210. very good good what do y'all do for
a living
I'm a deputy safeguards and security
manager for a doe subcontractor at the
Oak Ridge National Lab oh yeah okay and
I take care of him
he takes care of all of us guarding the
radioactive secrets and you take care of
him it's a fair trade yeah it's a fair
trade very good very good so uh what
kind of debt was 126 000. oh we had
everything from uh fifth wheel campers
to motorcycles to cars to IRS you know
no student debt or anything like that
but lots of toys yeah okay normal so uh
what happened what happened 22 months
ago like what was the wake up you did oh
how did I do that well I mean we never
felt a pinch of of being broke we never
understood being broke we never had a an
aha moment because you know in my in my
mind we weren't broke we had plenty of
money we made our payments it all came
in it all went out yeah okay yeah I mean
everything's good so
um I was actually started listening to
your show on the way home from work just
trying to find some kind of
entertainment something besides music to
listen to so I come on and you were
going through it one of the Dave Rants
and you were just I mean hammering
somebody this guy's pretty cool I'm I'm
gonna listen to him he's fine you know
and uh so we were listening for more
entertainment value than I was
educational value at the time until he
got mad at you yeah yeah and then I got
personal yeah
what did I step on you called me an
idiot and a more on there
and a broke brother
[Laughter]
well I told a friend of mine I said that
Dave Ramsey got he called me an idiot
today and he said well did you talk to
him I said no he was just on the air
he's he's talking about you then not
tell you I said yeah yeah there you go
okay talk about something you did
what did you do that I was picking on I
mean everything I'm just what you said
I'm the broke brother-in-law I'm the
broke neighbor I'm I'm uh you know I was
a with money you know I thought I
told her I said you know we make too
much money and and we're too smart for
for this you know and like I said I
never thought what did y'all do then did
you did you sell some of the toys uh we
sold our camper but we were upside down
in the camper so we sold it and still
had to come up with thirty thousand
dollars good Lord yeah so them them
things are how much are the 126 was the
camper 30.
no you said you had to come up with 30.
you were upside down 30. yeah wow okay
but I mean but you owed more than 30 on
it yeah we owed almost 90 on that's what
I meant so of the 126.90 was the camper
yes sir whoa okay so then you had to
come up with a 30 and then what yeah
that yeah that's a big move right there
yeah okay so that one that was the whoa
that was emotional when that left oh
yeah yeah I mean we we took pictures of
us with a guy driving office waving at
the camper on the way back just you know
go go go go go go before I changed my
mind yeah yeah so what did it look like
okay you're
because Dave's called you every name in
the book and you're like you're like we
have to get on board Jill what did you
say were you like yes I've been waiting
for this moment or were you like
um I'm not ready like tell me tell me
more about that getting on the same page
what what did you just say to me no I
was okay with it you were yeah I was
okay with it I knew we needed uh we
needed to do something and uh and we
made it happen so what'd that look like
what was that getting on a budget were
you trimming back uh well he he sat down
and he did he's better with the the
numbers and the the planning I'm the
nerd okay okay
um so he sat down and and he said okay I
think this is what we need to do this is
how we need to do it and we just started
I started clipping coupons and I started
which I'm not a big shopper like I've
never been one to go out and spend a lot
of money on clothes you know things like
that
um so that wasn't an issue but I did
start thrifting and yard selling a
little bit more than I used to okay so I
love to do that and uh DIY and some
stuff so that worked out so very good
yeah it's very good how's it feel now
that you're free
amazing how long y'all been married 15
years we'll be 16 and I've never been
dead for even while you're married no no
no wait again I wrote a check on my 49th
birthday which was two weeks ago I wrote
that check in my 49th birthday and we're
debt free
wow you know I'm almost I wanted to do
it by the time I was 50. yeah and you
did and and we did we did it at 49. yeah
you did excellent excellent
man way to go you guys all right when
somebody says how did you do that what
do you tell them the key was
I would just we had the plan stuck to it
we downloaded the every dollar app we
stuck to our budget you know and there
were uh you know I was listening to the
shows and stuff and you you would give
us some hints on what to do with the
budget and moving some things around and
we spent a little more this month on
this so we pulled it from somewhere else
um
but just sticking through that budget
and sticking with it and believing in
yourself yeah and leaving what you can
do and and with me I'm always the
when I get mad I get determined and like
I'm slow down yeah I wasn't mad at Dave
for calling me an idiot but I was mad
and then I got I got matted to debt and
and that's and that's what happened I we
just got mad we stuck to it and said
this is it I'm ready to kick it I'm done
and uh and that kind of determination
just really we had to really really you
know you have to work together you can't
if you know you get you start to get
frustrated like you know I really want
to do this or I want to do that well we
can't we can't go on that vacation and
it's like okay you know what we can't we
just can't do it right now on on her
47th birthday
47th I love to Everything's a Dollar
when I go yard sales oh it was just a
dollar it was just a dollar I got this
for a dollar so nothing's in the budget
I can't do this can't do that
um so my mother-in-law gave me a uh
birthday card and it had 47 one dollar
bills in it and she said this is in the
budget 47 one time you get 47 Things She
Said spend it at a you know thrift store
yard sale or whatever so I thought that
was pretty cool very well done I like
that very that means she was cheering
you on oh yeah her family yeah my mom
his parents yeah they're great that's
very good yeah very cool all right I've
been doing that free screams for uh
almost 30 years here on the air you're
the first trampus oh good that I've had
I'm a first show that means uh your mom
and dad must have been like fans of the
Virginians
that's an old TV show you got to be old
to know what that is yeah I was a month
early and they didn't have a name picked
out yet and when mom went to have me dad
was still waiting in the waiting room
and watching the TV show when The
Virginian came on there it is and that
was his favorite character so when the
nurse came out they said we need a name
he said name him Krampus we'll change it
later it was a great character that's a
great character and never changed it
yeah no no that's good I like that
that's fun congratulations thank you
thank you hey we've got a copy of the
baby steps millionaires book for you
that's the next step in your process The
Total Money Makeover book you can use it
or give it away in the Financial Peace
University membership same thing use it
or give away that's the live and give
box you either live it or you give it or
some of each we'd love to have you do
all that thank you guys for coming hey
Your Heroes thank you so much very good
thank you very good you're amazing very
very cool yeah that's a tough thing
y'all did it's really hard and it's
really worth it I'm proud of you trap us
in jail Knoxville Tennessee 126
000 paid off in 22 months making 110 to
210. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
yeah
yeah that's how you do it absolutely
amazing
you never know how those rants are going
to be taken look he was yelling at me
he's calling me names that's the way I
felt back in the day did you ruin a
little bit a little bit you called me
dumb through the magic of the radio
waves through the uh through the
millions of people that were listening
you were the one I selected yes yes okay
you know Dave you have that power your
voice follows people around it haunts
you it haunts you yes well it's also why
I have such a fan club on Twitter
that's right
yeah I can breed trolls like nobody can
breathe in trouble
it is but the people that know us know
that uh the only reason we would do
something like that is because we love
you we're there to help you and if you
think otherwise you just misunderstood
the whole idea this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial piece and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Christy
is in Phoenix hi Christy how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up
[Music]
well my husband and I own a franchise
it's a restaurant
um I don't really want to say the name
but
we have a business own a pretty hefty
business loan
which
so are we oh 230 on the business
and we have about that exactly 230
equity in our home would you sell your
home to pay off the business loan
because the interest rate just keeps
going up enough and up and our payments
are now we've owned this restaurant for
three and a half years and we
started paying 2500 a month and now we
are at 4 500 a month because of the
interest rate
would you sell your house to pay off
your business loan
are you making money
yes we're making money but how much
what's your pro what's your taxable
income in 2023 going to be
like take homes no taxable income what
are you going to pay taxes on what's
your tax return going to tell me you
made the real profit of the real profit
maybe like 700 000. won't you just pay
it off
you're going to pay taxes on seven
hundred thousand dollars profit
maybe not that maybe not a profit that
might be gross all the numbers that
might be gross revenue
it might be you're right what do you
take home do you know that
out of the business pay ourselves a
salary from the business yeah what is
that or and that's about 45 000.
each and then he retired from the Army
so he has each
um no together so you make a forty five
thousand dollar salary okay at the end
of the year was there six hundred
thousand dollars laying around in an
account
then you did not make a seven hundred
thousand dollar profit
okay then no I'm I'm really excited
profit gross revenue is the total money
coming in then minus expenses equals
profit does that make sense
yes okay and I hope to God you made more
than forty five thousand dollars on
seven hundred thousand dollars worth of
income do you guys have money laying
around in any
savings for the business
we do so
so right now to get us through our
winter we live where it's kind of it's
hard to make it through the winter so we
have fifty thousand to get us through
the winner this coming winter
and 25 000 we just put away for savings
and then we have another that's in a
savings account then we have another 25
000 in cash
okay
so it's a little hard for me to tell you
what to do because I can't figure out
whether you're making any money or not
you've been doing this three years and
it sounds like you've gathered up but I
was here and then you had to go to the
dentist
and stuff so here's here's the let me
kind of give you the concept and then
you and your husband can talk through it
the concept is I would sell my home only
if I can't figure out a way to clear
this debt in about three years
which means you would need to make more
than more than you know you after you
pay your bills and eat you need to make
an extra 75 to 100 000 a year to throw
at this loan
okay and I don't know if this restaurant
is producing that or not it doesn't
sound like it is so it does sound like
you have made a mistake and you've
overpaid for this franchise and this
mess you've gotten yourself into and it
probably cost you your home you're
probably going to have to sell your home
or you're going to end up bankrupt is
this the only is the business the only
money coming in or do you guys have
other side jobs she he has he had
military retirement okay military
retirement yeah is that it
yes okay yeah yeah you guys need to
figure out but it sounds like you guys
are making maybe a hundred thousand
dollars a year off of this total
including the money you're setting back
and the money you're taking home and all
that
um and that that means you're probably
going to have this debt around for four
five six years if you keep your house so
the fact that you overpaid for this
restaurant you got excited and the fact
that you went into debt to buy the
restaurant uh and which you should not
have done by the way
um then I would not have done this deal
uh uh but you're there now yeah and
those things are forcing you to sell
your house
um so it's as if at the beginning of
this whole project you said
I want to own this restaurant more than
I want to own my house you didn't mean
to say that but that's what it comes
it's what it's going to come down to and
so I unless you guys can figure out that
you can pull a hundred thousand seventy
five to a hundred thousand out of the
business and throw it at the debt and
still pay your bills at home and eat
for the next two to three years if you
can do that for three years you're out
of debt
okay and it but I don't think this
thing's generating that now maybe it
will start but the fact that you have
down Winters in the restaurant business
is weird yeah I I felt the same things
yeah I had I had more questions but you
know I think
45 to earn 45 000 a year off of business
just doesn't feel worth it it's not
they're making more than that but not
much yeah all right open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money will is with us will
is in Atlanta Georgia hi will welcome to
the Ramsey Show hey Dave thanks for
having me sure how can we help
um I have thirty thousand dollars in
gold and silver I'm sorry and I have
twenty and I have 25 000 in debt and I
was wondering if I should pay that off
yes
thanks for calling because I get married
yeah yes yes I get married in nine days
and my pastor and I we went through
marriage counseling and do you recognize
recommended me to talk to you okay and I
just wanted to see yeah let's reverse it
okay let's say you were debt free and
you were getting married in nine days
would you go borrow thirty thousand
dollars to buy gold and silver nine days
before you get married
oh no no
you would not so we're gonna revert
we're going to reverse engineer and
it'll give you the instant answer that
Jade gave you sell the gold and silver
now today and be debt free and before
your honeymoon
it'll change the way you walk it'll
change the way you talk the rituals over
the poor and the borrower is slave to
the lender that's what your pastor was
talking about and when you are no longer
a slave you can devote yourself to your
new bride and two-year-old's bright and
shiny future and it's not bright and
shiny because it's gold or silver it's
bright and shiny because you're smart
enough to never do this crap again yeah
the next time you start investing in
baby step four make sure you're going
into mutual funds and not gold not
silver not single stocks well we're
gonna give you Financial Peace
University which is our nine week class
on how to handle money as our wedding
gift you and your wife go through that
after you get home from the honeymoon
okay some people are so nerdy they do
that on their honeymoon that's just
weird don't do that I don't want to go
on I don't I'm on the video I don't want
to go on the honeymoon with you okay so
wait till you get home but we're going
to give it to you for free and get you
signed up and get you going
so open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five those of you that
want to know a little bit more about
money we're doing a free live stream of
our first two hours of the smart
conference in Chicago Saturday morning
we would love to have you do that with
us uh Jade will be speaking and George
camel will be speaking in the first two
hours and we're live streaming those two
talks completely free just go to
ramseysolutions.com live and we'll get
you signed up for that and get you going
you do not want to miss that Dr John
deloney's book building a non-anxious
life is rapidly building its sales to be
a number one best seller it comes out
October the 3rd just a couple of weeks
from now and if you wanted all the
pre-sale goodies that we give you twenty
dollars for the book The 75 worth of
goodies if you pre-buy it you can get
all of that now at ramseysolutions.com
lots of things happening right now
that's right around here a lot of things
I I mean you can come to the smart
conference if you're in the Chicago area
we'll be there Friday heading up there
in the morning and we'll be there Friday
evening and Saturday all day and we'd
love to have you there's a few tickets
left you can still get in
ramseysolutions.com events in other
words a lot of the stuff you want to do
you'll find over at ramsesolutions.com
we appreciate you guys hanging out with
us this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for jumping in
America it's a free call Jayden warshaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Lisa is with us in Colorado Springs hi
Lisa welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi Jade I I'm a long time
listener and a steadier of the um baby
steps and but a first-time caller so I'm
excited to be here well thank you for
being with us how can we help
or to pay off old slash bad like try to
pay off debt
um
old bad debt can usually be settled for
pennies on the dollar
um
uh to give you an example we bought a
couple of years ago as a Christmas
present for our team we bought 10
million dollars worth of old bad medical
debt repo debt and credit card debt
and
um there were um
8 000 accounts
and we bought that for 250 000 bucks
and we called all the people and forgave
their debt that was our Christmas
present it was so fun it was so fun yeah
we got we have a thousand team members
each of them got to call eight people
and tell them Jesus forgave their debt
and so um wow so it was pretty cool it
was kind of fun but the point is not to
brag on us but the point is 10 million
dollars for 250 000. that's uh two and a
half cents on the dollar wow
that's two and a half percent is what we
paid for it okay okay so if you had one
of those debts and you called one of
those people they would have settled
that for 10 or 20 cents on the dollar
easy
so if one of those was a ten thousand
dollar debt and uh we bought it for 25
you could have bought it probably for
100 or 150 dollars
you know something like that right or we
bought it okay ten thousand dollar debt
we bought it for 250 bucks you could
have paid it off probably for twelve
hundred so point is Pennies on the
dollar so let's let's back up and talk
about the real world with you how much
old bad debt do you have and what kind
of debt is it
excellent okay so it's actually not me
I'm I'm calling for uh because I I'm
dealing with my mom and my dad okay so
my dad passed away
um back at the beginning of the year I'm
sure
um he yeah um you know but God is good
and I know where he's at so we're just
celebrating his life and trying to uh
Wade through how much do they have
so he had
um between him and my mother about a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars what
kind of death and it's five to ten plus
years old or Consumer Debt
like credit cards
it would be credit cards
um he had a small business and
um his small business he used debt to
finance you know to finance his business
and so yeah so does Mom have any money
right so Mom has
um about twenty thousand dollars in
Saving
savings does Mom have a house
mom has a house it's worth about three
hundred thousand and but it has a
reverse mortgage on it for about
145. what state is she in
she's in Texas
okay
yeah she does also have some
um
I would call it a delinquent gun so that
was also used to try and split the
business that's actually all in her name
and it's like I would say 90 plus days
old and there's about a 15 000 of that
okay all right does anyone in your
family have any money you or brothers or
sisters
um I we're working my husband and I are
working through the baby steps right now
so we have um we have nothing that can't
uh nothing that's not going to get right
now okay
um I have a an older brother who is
newly married and a savings are the
answer yeah and my my younger brother I
actually have no idea how old's your mom
she is 73. okay let me talk you back
through this room philosophically
bankruptcy
um I've been through it when I was in my
20s it's horrible right okay
philosophically it's right on the same
list as divorce
right it's a horrible thing it's never a
good thing it's never a pleasant thing
it's not something you want to do and if
you think you might be facing it you try
everything else
to try to avoid it before you do it you
want to pull out all the stops right
never never do it that's your absolute
last last last Last Resort
because it's not a wealth building tool
there's a lot of UN
intended consequences that come at you
because of it it you know you don't want
to do it if you can avoid it okay just
like you don't you know like you're
talking to a young couple that's had a
fight you don't you're not divorced you
just had a fight okay so uh it's the
same thing and and so
you know front number one I put it in
that bucket number two just like divorce
Dave Ramsey never tells you to do it
there are I've never in 30 years been on
the air and said you need to file
bankruptcy or you need to file divorce
the one exception on divorce is if
somebody is getting uh I have told a
couple ladies that are getting beat
getting you know domestic violence
situations that they need to file
divorce they need to get out of there
okay but other than that I don't tell
people to do stuff like that they make
their own decisions I just understand if
they end up doing it I'm not mad at you
if you end up doing it I went through it
but I wouldn't not divorced by
bankruptcy but I would tell you not to
if there's any way you can so all of
that to say all of that to say does your
mom have an income
she receives like 800 a month for Social
Security and then she drives lists
um I remember correctly in Texas your
home is protected in bankruptcy
bankruptcy yes in Texas in Texas and
Florida both have 100 Homestead and uh
so if she files bankruptcy they won't
touch her home they and they will allow
her to keep X number of dollars of cash
probably five or ten thousand but not
much and everything else will be
collected by the bankruptcy courts and
used towards her debts what I would
attempt to do is to help her to begin to
solve this for somewhere around a dime
on the dollar
okay if she can make this all go away
for ten or twelve thousand dollars and a
lot of phone calls by you on her behalf
beating the crap out of these people and
you're gonna have to beat the crap out
of them you're gonna have to say Widow
lady in Texas files bankruptcy you get
nothing this is going to be the headline
if you screw with me
I'm offering you this don't mess with me
you better take the deal
because if you don't take the deal I'm
gonna hang up the phone and go to the
next one and when the money runs out
you're going to end up holding nothing
zero so go through and try to settle
these 10 15 cents on the dollar and I
think you can help her avoid it but boy
you got an uphill battle you do not have
a lot of resources to settle this with
so it could be done but it's going to be
tough it'll be tough if you run out of
money you run out of patience you run
out of steam she may end up filing and I
won't be mad at her but it won't be but
I but I would have tried everything else
first this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and
Catholic you can tailor the content
towards your faith tradition if you
don't have a faith
great place to learn more about it from
scripture readings and prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and to
remember Halo is giving you 90 days free
imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hallow.com
Ramsay today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is our co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jade let's talk
bankruptcy for a minute
a Chapter 13 is the most popular type of
bankruptcy that's a repayment plan where
you pay back a portion of your debt some
debts a hundred percent if they're uh
secured debt like a car loan is paid
back a hundred percent uh if it's a
student loan it's paid back a hundred
percent if it's a credit card debt a
medical bill it can be paid back at
Pennies on the dollar but you pay
payments according to your income in a
Chapter 13 over 60 months five years
and then the debts that were partially
paid in the plan the rest of them are
forgiven and uh in bankruptcy but you
have filed bankruptcy now sometimes
chapter 13 people don't think that's a
bankruptcy because it's a payment plan
no you filed federal bankruptcy that's a
Chapter 13 Bankruptcy a chapter 12
bankruptcy is a farm
situation very unusual bankruptcy a
chapter 11 is a very large bankruptcy
usually you see corporations do that big
companies do that like they'll uh like a
Bed Bath and Beyond they'll follow
chapter 11 and they'll dump 75 percent
of their stores and they cut all the all
the leases loose and they keep the
profitable stores and then they restart
the company
so it's a reorganization for a large
amount of money typically a large
company a business an ongoing concern
the when people think of bankruptcy
generally what we think of is Chapter 7
bankruptcy which is total bankruptcy and
that's where
quote unquote all your debts are wiped
out
only they're not but that's the thing so
student loans are not bankruptible IRS
taxes are not bankruptible
so if you follow chapter seven and you
have IRS and you have student loans you
come out of the chapter seven you still
got those
uh if you want to keep something that
has a secured loan against it like you
keep a car payment you want to keep the
car with a payment on it you have to
re-affirm that debt
and just keep paying it you can bring it
current if you're behind and then you
re-sign that documents and you keep
going and you keep paying it or you give
up the car
but you can't get rid of the card debt
and keep the car that's not an option
they have a lien on the car in a chapter
seven so you're going to give up the car
or you're going to resign so I have had
people Jade come in and say we're going
to file bankruptcy only we're going to
reaffirm the car and the rest of our
debt student loans and IRS well you
didn't file bankruptcy on anything then
yeah there was no no relief from the
bankruptcy you receive everything's
surviving yeah so stupid stupid don't do
that a Chapter 7 bankruptcy stays on
your credit bureau report for 10 years
it's the only thing that stays on 10
years
everything else stays on for seven years
chapter 13 stays on seven years from the
date of last activity which is seven
years from five years from now
you started
payment plan so you end up 12 years
from today if you filed 13 today before
bankruptcies off of your credit bureau
report so these are the things they
don't talk about when everybody acts
like bankruptcy is easier bankruptcy is
quick or whatever yeah and what we were
talking to her about is when you file
bankruptcy they give you a personal
exemption per state the state that you
live in even though bankruptcy's federal
court the the exemptions are by State
and they give you a homestead exemption
the homestead exemption is the amount of
your home equity that you're allowed to
keep
and so you can't have in Most states a
four hundred thousand dollar paid for
house and file bankruptcy and keep it
the bankruptcy trustee will take that
house and sell it they will give you the
exemption amount which in Tennessee is
seven thousand five hundred dollars wow
and so you will lose the house give
seven thousand five hundred dollars and
they will use the rest of your Equity to
pay your debts I that is painful
that's big that's painful that's big now
if you live in Florida Texas or Arkansas
they have a 100 homestead exemption so
they don't take your house
you can own a two million dollar paid
for house in Florida and file bankruptcy
and keep the house
question do you think they have a higher
rate of bankruptcy filings because of
that exemption no
that's the the data doesn't show that it
doesn't that's interesting because
bankruptcies are more based are based on
other things most people don't use
bankruptcy as a method to screw people
and you know generally if somebody's got
a two million dollar house most people
will sell the house and pay their bills
yeah even if they're in a state that
doesn't require them to do that in
bankruptcy okay because most people are
trying to do the right they're trying to
figure their way through this they don't
even but and but there's a few people
that you know yeah do stuff like this
but you know so that's a pretty vast
difference between Texas and say
Tennessee Tennessee seven thousand five
hundred dollars you get to keep Texas
should keep all of it no matter how big
it is if it's your personal residence
that's a big difference so like Kentucky
five thousand dollars Louisiana thirty
five thousand dollars I pulled up the
list on uh oh Google Google here so
Maine is 47.5 Maryland 22 975 where'd
they come up with that Massachusetts
500K
you can keep okay Michigan thirty
thousand Minnesota 450 Mississippi 75
000 Missouri fifteen thousand Nebraska
sixty thousand so yeah so you can see
it's all over the map but uh in all but
those three states if you have a super
expensive home that's paid for you don't
keep the home in a chapter seven
wow and you're gonna you're gonna be so
the point is
if if you're not going to get rid of
student loans you're not going to get
rid of the IRS and and you're going to
resign for the car
um and you know you you owe eight
thousand dollars on credit cards that's
the only thing that's going to go away
and you've lost your and you've lost
your amount and then you're going to
lose your home or you're going to be
handcuffed in some way or another it's
usually bankruptcy is not a big help
yeah that's just an atom bomb and not
really much gain from it yeah just
dropping an atom bomb on a tomato patch
I mean it's just you know there's not
it's a lot it's serious Overkill and so
um
you know that that's why a lot of times
but what happens is that people get so
scared they're terrorized by The Calling
the collector's calling and calling and
collectors are nasty they sure and
they're giving you a hard time and
they're doing all this stuff they get
scared and they go well I'm just I give
up I Surrender I'm gonna file Banker but
it doesn't fix it yeah you think about
the chapter 13 you think well you can
come up with a payment plan you can
negotiate these things down yourself
exactly and you if you do it our way
you're probably going to do it in less
than five years yeah yeah exactly
so um you know our last caller and and
you know we got up against commercial
break and you mentioned this in the
commercial break they had a reverse
mortgage yeah Mom and Dad the lady was
calling for her mom and dad
um they had a reverse mortgage which is
going to come back and bite her later
yeah because she can only pull out so
much Equity when the equity goes It goes
up to 65 alone to value and after that
they're going to stop and then she still
has to pay the taxes the insurance and
maintain the property and if they don't
the reverse mortgage company will
foreclose on her that's right and um
she's only going to drive Uber or Lyft
for so long right and she's 70. yeah
driving Uber so uh what's this tell us
well it tells us that Mom's probably
selling that house in the future
and the thing I didn't do in that call
that I probably should have and you
brought this up it was you you tell me
the truth was that they probably need to
sell the house now yeah before they run
out it gets rid of the reverse mortgage
and take the equity that's there it'll
clean up her debts as she settles them
she can get a nice little apartment and
live on Social Security and a little bit
of Uber or Lyft money yeah and not have
all this stuff hanging over her head I
agree
um but you know Daddy died in January
and here we said in September and Mama's
got all this stuff crashing down around
her ears and she's 70 and driving Uber
no my heart goes up to them the thing
I'm gonna you know now we're gonna sell
her house that's gonna be really hard
yeah it is going to be hard and she's
probably not going to want to do it or
understand why yeah but but you've been
running a business for 15 years at a
loss and you got 120 000 in credit card
debt and that's where it came from so
that's you know this is the the chickens
coming home to roost as they say but
it's very difficult but really what what
when Mama and when that lady is 75 years
old what is the best course of action
for her to have taken I sell the house
right now yeah absolutely clean up all
the debt settle it all she's 100 debt
free she's in an apartment and all the
pressure's off that's right and all the
shame and the condemnation from the
bills from the past and all the
collectors calling in a year that she's
grieving her husband's death it's all
gone it's all cleaned up
you know I wish I thought of that while
I had the lady on the air they're still
listening Maybe
[Music]
it's tough stuff this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
phones this hour at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Jade warshaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Michael is with us hey
Michael how are you man I'm doing great
Dave how are you better than I deserve
where do you live uh Torrington
Connecticut Connecticut welcome to
Nashville and how much debt have you
paid off sir about forty thousand
dollars in uh 13 months good for you
range of income during that time started
at around 60 and finished just over 100k
excellent what kind of debt did you have
uh I had a car note about 23 000 on a
car uh 8 000 in various medical debts uh
seven and a half K on credit cards and
about 1500 on miscellaneous
uh small debts yeah you were normal yeah
pretty normal I think normal what
happened what was the deal 13 months ago
well I just I thought I was doing a good
job keeping up with the Joneses I had a
decent condo nice car and um you know I
just found that I was stressed and
anxious all the time and uh I know I'm a
single parent and that stuff bleeds down
to our kids and um I don't know I just
decided that I really wanted a better
life uh for both of us so that's around
when I found the Ramsey Show good for
you so the stress of the debt wasn't
worth it to you definitely not no wow
then how old's your baby uh she's 13.
all right very good good for you so how
did you find the Ramsay Bunch uh just uh
looking up on YouTube I found you and um
I think you were doing
um you were on a rant a kind of an
anti-snow flakery rant and I was like
that is my guy yes and uh that's what I
you know that's when I really became
interested in the show and um yeah the
heat the heat from those Ranch has been
known to melt entire inches of
snowflakes yeah so wow it was just what
I needed to hear
so great so you were a recovering snow
you've recovered oh he's not a snowman
well no no I wasn't a snowfall
he agreed with me and that meant I might
have something else
it definitely got my attention I like it
very good and um so
um I just basically I just went to work
I mean my side jobs have side jobs I
work so many jobs what was the most
lucrative sad thing you did the thing
that made the most money uh well I'm a
chef by trade and probably
it's hard to say but probably I did a
lot of 1099 catering jobs that were very
lucrative that's cool like some private
shifting that's some good money yeah
very good money in that and um I do a
lot of deliveries food and grocery
deliveries and the reason why those have
been so great is because my daughter
likes to come with me
um so it's kind of a way to work extra
hours
um
at the same time yeah she's she's been
my navigator my DJ my traveling comedian
for thousands of deliveries well and you
know if she's doing the DJing the
music's much better than if you did she
would definitely agree with you on that
day for sure sure I'm sure 100 yeah very
good man very cool so what kind of money
can you make doing the side chefing idea
um that it's it's all it's over fifty
dollars an hour right yeah that's great
it's awesome and that's a lot more than
I make in any of my other jobs
um but you know good for you it's nice
to mix it up a little bit yeah but I
mean that's again usually we find find
the best side gigs are an extension of
your professional absolutely so like
teachers that do tutoring can make 40 or
50 an hour that's another side gig that
kind of stuff we see that all the time
but just taking what you're doing in
your professional world and and moving
it around that way good stuff man so uh
who is your biggest cheerleader other
than your 13 year old
I had
a co-workers that cheered me on I think
most people uh most friends and family
probably think I'm a little crazy
um you know yeah I am in a good way yeah
and I'm proud to say uh you know
disregarding the credit score and all
that is it's a tough sell to a lot of
people you know a lot of my family but
they but they've always supported me and
encouraged me they may not agree with it
but now that you've paid off 40 Grand in
13 months do they believe it all I don't
know I hope so it's pretty good I hope
they do it speaks volumes right there
that you actually did it it's not what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is I would say definitely uh
budgeting was the number one thing for
me it was something I had never done
before I couldn't have even told you how
much I made a year how much how much
debt I had honestly I had no idea
because I had never laid it out like
that and so uh using every dollar was uh
a big big help for me I still use it now
that's cool very good very good good for
you man that's proud of you way to go
hero how's your feel deal to be free I
can't tell you how great it feels I've
never fallen asleep so fast that night
before my head even hits the pillow
because I just don't you know I used to
stress out about you know the next
paycheck and the next bill that's due
and and yeah I just don't worry about
that anymore you just don't have to and
it's just a great feeling and I just
encourage people that um even if you're
a single parent you can definitely do it
um
you know just start budgeting and get to
work yeah let them be your DJ yeah let's
go here we go amen very exciting good
stuff really really cool all right we've
got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure
you're on your way hero and uh Total
Money Makeover book and you can give
that to somebody if they actually
inquire about how you pulled this off
and the same thing for Financial Peace
University so that's the live and give
box and it'll get you uh get you
something you can live and some you can
give so good stuff I know your
daughter's not gonna join you on stage
but let's honor her anyway what as the
DJ what's her name that's Clara my
daughter Clara way to go Clara
appreciate you supporting your dad and
your dad's a hero you ought to you ought
to tell him he's awesome because he is
very cool stuff good job all right
Michael from Connecticut 40 000 paid off
the side hustles had side hustles he did
it in 13 months making 60 to 100 counted
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one I'm debt free yeah
so Jade uh in the program today we've
had two debt free screams both of them
said that every dollar the every dollar
budgeting app was key it is key
stop explaining it most people I think I
read a stat that said 70 or 77 percent
of Americans if you say hey what did you
spend last month that I couldn't tell
you I mean I do because they don't have
any I mean they really do not track it
at all you don't track it and when you
start tracking it there's a rule in
business that says what gets measured
gets done that's so good and same thing
is true with money if you don't measure
it if you don't tell your money what to
do you'll always wonder where it went
the ever dollar budgeting app is the
world's best budgeting app we brag about
it because but it really is it's
legitimately amazing uh you can try it
completely for free and this coming
Tuesday George Campbell is going to be
doing one of our budgeting webinars
Jade's already done a few Rachel's done
a few y'all are going to be doing some
more later that's right this coming
Tuesday George Campbell is back after
he's his wife just had a brand new baby
and they've been at home for a while but
he's back he's going to be with us in
Chicago this weekend but then this
coming Tuesday he'll be doing the uh the
every dollar webinar he'll be online uh
we limit that because you get to
interact with him with questions during
the process people jump in that's right
and so if you want to be part of the
webinar there on this coming Tuesday
George Campbell is going to be doing it
on putting together every Dodge
completely free
it's completely free
so you just go to everydollar.com
budgeting and you can learn how to do
some of the stuff that Michael did he
paid off forty thousand dollars in 13
months yeah it's so necessary and so
many people think oh I have a budget I
do it on paper every month but it's not
the same because when you go on every
dollar when you track you're tracking
each day what you're spending to make
sure you're actually hitting your
numbers it's not just you setting it and
forgetting it right right and that to me
is the key I mean you can set a budget
and forget it and it's not really a
budget no it was a it was just a list
yeah exactly it is exactly what it was
and so you know in business we have you
know you have your budget for the month
and then you have your actual for the
month and you say okay we brought in
more revenue or less Revenue than we
thought over or under budget we spent
more or less than we thought over and
our profits were over or under and you
compare what you plan to do with what
you actually did yes and every dollar
does that minute by minute yeah when
you're doing it in real time you can
adjust as opposed to waiting till the
end of the month going oh crap because
you can't keep spending more than you
make you're not in Congress that's right
everydollar.com budgeting George
Campbell gonna be this coming Tuesday
the 19th of September free webinar sign
up for it this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
scripture of the day Hebrews 12 11 no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but painful later on however it produces
a harvest of righteousness and peace for
those who have been trained to buy it
Abraham Lincoln said discipline is
choosing between what you want now and
what you want most oh
that's good
Catherine is in Minneapolis hi Catherine
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello Dave I am super excited to talk to
you you too what's up
I have um I've been listening to you
since I was 25 years old I lived right
there in Franklin Tennessee now I'm 54
and I live in Wisconsin right outside of
Minnesota
and I have a question my husband and I
well I followed you like I said for
years
um we have two we're both optometrists
um he's also a farmer and I'm also a
yoga instructor we have been practicing
Optometry for about 29 years we are
completely out of debt that happened
about four years ago we feel very
blessed we worked really hard way to go
where thank you
um we're wondering if you might have
some advice of where to go now we were
all with driving bigger when we were
trying to get out of debt you know
checking off of our boxes and all of
that and now that we've done that we've
got about four and a half years left
that we want to do Optometry before we
retire but we're we're sailing burned
out we're not feeling that drive and
that Vigor and that sense of
accomplishment and checking things off
and we're just wondering if you have any
advice of
I don't know where to go from here and
like I said I feel very blessed even
speaking this question
um so you've paid off the debt house and
everything
house and everything oh yeah way to go
that's amazing right congratulations
your house got paid up thank you and we
feel very proud
um but now we're just trying to figure
out how to keep that drive going and to
be able to work for the next four and a
half years well in some ways you don't
need the same drive as far as that
intensity because it's like oh I'm
paying off dead I'm doing this you've
earned the right to take your foot off
the gas obviously you have all of this
margin now right so you're doing those
three things that we always do with
money we're giving some of it we're
saving more of it and we're spending it
and I think that that's kind of what you
guys need to this is the good part right
this is a fun part where you sit down I
know and you look at that margin you're
like okay because here's the thing
you've got it you've got to give
something because then you realize this
is what this is all for right you've got
to keep that perspective and the more
you give you realize that you've got to
spend some of it because if you don't
it's like all we do is work work work
right and you're not enjoying it so
you've got to spend some of it and then
of course you've got to continue to save
because you are thinking about the
future you are thinking about this life
that you want to have so right that's
really that's really all there is to it
now I get what you're saying because you
are in this mindset for however many
years of I'm just stacking away I'm
going going and it's kind of hard to
turn that off what I have what I what I
did was
um I found that in not only in business
but from a Ministry perspective and uh
from a financial perspective I get a lot
of energy from a detailed goal
that's my husband yeah and it doesn't
even matter what it is as long as it's
detailed and it and I can measure
progress towards that goal okay it could
be a generosity goal it could be uh we
want to go on this trip and we want to
save towards that it could be uh uh you
know a a friend of mine just bought a
big classic car that he's thought of for
the last 20 years he wanted to buy and
that was a big goal he worked towards he
said now what do I do I said you need
another goal I don't care what it is get
you a goal you know and uh and so uh you
know one of the most fun ones we've had
Sharon and I have had and we're in the
same place I mean baby step seven and at
the ends of our careers right and so
forth was I ran into this guy who uh not
counting his tithe and his normal rhythm
of giving in addition to that he had a
goal he wanted to give away a million
dollars in a year
two Ministries just to give to other
help other people right and um so we set
that as a goal and we were able to do it
one year and that was so much fun and
then we decided I want then I decided a
few years ago and we did this about
three years ago I think or four uh I
guess it was here before covid maybe we
said uh I want to give away a million
dollars in in one day
that was fun that's crazy that was crazy
you know and I'm a kid from Antioch
Tennessee man I I can't even I couldn't
even wrap my head around having a
million dollars much less giving away a
million much less giving away a million
in one day let me know the next time
you're planning on doing that and let me
put my hand let me put my name in the
Hat
right but I mean I'm not bragging I'm
just saying the point the point is that
the stuff we teach works and it puts you
in a position if you live like no one
else later you can live and give like no
one else and so what you need then is
something that matters to you
that is a very clearly defined high
definition goal to where you will know
exactly how close you are to it and when
you hit it
it's not vague it's not some sin it's
not some feeling it's very objective
very measurable and you say okay by this
date we want to do this and then your
mind automatically starts unpacking uh
what my friend Henry Cloud says he says
what must be true that's not true today
in order to be there at that date yeah
that's right what is it that in order to
give that save that uh you know I want
this I want to be in a position I mean
you I don't mind the vague ones that are
kind of funny I used to work for a guy
that was real motivational he was a
great guy he said I want to make enough
money I can read the menu left to right
instead of looking at the price first on
what I'm going to order I'm going to
look at the stuff decide what I want to
order and then I'll notice the price
that's right he said that's a that's a
state of mind now that's a little bit
weird a little bit funny but but it is
mindset it is it is I've gotten
comfortable I've gotten content uh this
meal is not gonna oh yeah find me I can
do whatever I want to do with this meal
it's like what you said about Sharon
wanting to be able to just go to the
store and you know you can put what you
want in the basket and it's not a it's
not a thing it's a buggy I can't say it
I can't I can't go there she wanted to
go to the grocery store and filled up
her buggy I said that on the live stream
the other night and Rachel and Jade made
so much fun of me when I got off the air
they're like a bug you know you did it
on the air we make fun of me in front of
your face that's not a buggy it's a cart
it's not a cart it's a buggy a basket a
cart a shopping cart if you will it's
not a baby buggy it is a I don't know
that's what we cost anyway she wanted to
be able to go to the grocery store and
buy groceries without thinking about it
yeah because we were so broke that we
had to squeeze every dime on every
paycheck on everything we couldn't
breathe that's how I feel I I relate to
Sharon in that way so much that was my
thing is I I want to know that we can
but now we can budget enough to where I
don't have to be think I don't I'm not
calculating it as I go right yeah I
guess if you've ever been where you
didn't know if you could feed your kids
you weren't 100 sure you could feed your
kids we all they always got fed we
weren't but it was it was touch and go
yeah you know if you've ever been there
where that's a different kind of Terror
yeah and if you've ever been there then
you know going to the grocery store and
filling up your buggy filling up your
cart with anything you want to put in it
that becomes a really solid goal that's
funny and the funny thing is like I said
the other night she's such a tight wad
she still doesn't do it but and now she
could buy the grocery store but you know
but that doesn't matter she just goes in
there and gets whatever fill up your
buggy open up your pocketbook and pay
for it yeah that's it that's it
you didn't get it if you say buggy you
also say pocketbook what's wrong with
pocketbook it's a wallet
it's not a wallet it's a purse a
pocketbook and a purse of the same thing
no your pocketbook is your wallet right
no Booth guys no wait a second I've only
ever heard pocketbook in like a woman's
purse context purse it's a purse
yeah open it okay my mama carried her
pocketbook
yeah
that's that's I remember that my whole
life I don't well if you grow up wallet
you know I only know these phrases
because I have family in Virginia so
that's how I know about it
we can keep you on here long enough
we're going to teach you to speak
hillbilly I'm just saying I'm getting
close
you keep your pocketbook in your buggy
that's right that's what you do when
you're shopping oh my gosh Bobby
Robertson's from Alabama is that true
Bobby you keep your pocketbook in your
body okay that's what it is
oh good stuff guys in the booth great
job today as always we appreciate you
the booth dude says always doing a great
job Jade warshaw good job as well I am
Dave Ramsey your host will be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]